now the next quarterback I want to get
into is the Jets and the Zack Wilson
Saga there were reports this week that
the Jets want to go back to Zack Wilson
but he is reluctant my thoughts on the
situation
right
now a lot of you said y'all wanted to
get rid of Zack Wilson and y'all shamed
him and and I truly do believe Zack
Wilson was definitely reading the media
he got blamed by the media he got blamed
by
everyone when Co Sal
said they they that was their best
option at quarterback right and you
thought anybody can just play
quarterback in the NFL because y'all
just think quarterback is just the
easiest job which is not and that's why
I do understand why the MVP um of the
league it's it's probably the hardest
position on
NFL without a
doubt but as fans right I'm a fan of the
game and I'm a fan of football uh I'm a
fan of the just everything about
football and I obviously I'm blessed
enough to play and I'm best blessed
enough to play at the highest level so
understanding you're you're telling me
right you got some of the highest paid
athletes best athletes in the world all
scheming up to slow down another
team there's a lot of game plan there's
a lot of intelligent players
right
they're
we do everything to slow down this man
right and this man has to do everything
in his power to make sure we don't slow
him down has his execution been great no
it hasn't and we're just gonna be honest
Zack Wilson's execution hasn't been
great but in reality he's a good enough
player to win games he has won games and
in some of the the hardest league in the
world
right Bryce young he's struggling to win
games it it's common like it's it's a
hard position position to play and it
takes a lot of blame right if I go out
and miss two sacks or don't do no
production and Dak throws for 400 and
maybe three picks and we lose the
game no one cares about what I did and
and that's the reality and you can say
I'm one of the better players of the
Cowboys and I'm one of the bigger faces
of the Cowboys but in reality no one
cares what I did everyone cares about
what your quarterback did and if he
performed enough and bet good enough to
win that is some of the hardest part
about football right and being a
quarterback especially and he's a New
York New York's huge in football they
love football uh New York media and you
guys deliberately and int
tempul killed this man's confidence y'
y' y' y'all single-handed broke him down
and to the point where this man I don't
even know if he really wants to play
there anymore or if he feels he needs
needs a new
start but it it's tough for him and I
and I get why he's like man I don't
think I can succeed on this team and
sometimes you can succeed on a team
right you see it between Kurt Cousins
how he was before and when he got to
Minnesota he started playing better it
sometimes it's just like that right but
this is what I would say if I'm Zach
right and you know this team may move on
from me um you have this narrative that
is painted against you and you have an
opportunity to fix it that's a bey thing
about life and if I are you I don't care
what no one says I don't care what no
one thinks I'mma go out here and just
play my brand of
football I'mma go out here and play my
brand of football and that's the best
thing you can do right because if you if
if I had five games left and I said this
is and and you almost have to put this
to the point where my life depends on
this right
your life depends on this this will
determine if you'll be in this the NFL
for years to come you have an
opportunity to not let your teammates
down get better and say I'm gonna play
my D Brandon football it doesn't matter
if I win or lose it doesn't matter I'm
going just go out here have fun and
remember why I played this game and then
you're going to buy yourself time to say
I could go win on another team I just
can't win here and people will respect
that but you have to give yourself that
opportunity to say I don't care what no
one else thinks I'mma go play my brand
of football and be great and that's how
I feel about that Zach so if you hear me
right now go play your brand of football
you only have a little bit left you have
four or five games left play your brand
of football and just go shine man who
cares what people thinks go Shine Go
shine and that's how I feel about
it